now to the pandemic there is good news
and bad news about that omicron surge
the new seven-day average for covades in
the u.s is approaching 2200 a day that's
the highest in nearly a year that's the
bad news but the cdc says fewer patients
have been admitted to the hospital
nationwide compared to previous waves
that's the good news hospitalizations
are still climbing in some parts of the
country where fewer people are
vaccinated including oklahoma chris van
cleave is at st anthony hospital that's
in oklahoma city chris good morning to
you
good morning oklahoma could lead the
nation this week in hospitalizations
because omicron is yet to peak here that
could also happen this week but there's
a staffing shortage hitting hospitals
here in oklahoma city hard they have 300
fewer available and staffed hospital
beds than they did a year ago and this
hospital says they haven't had an open
and available icu bed in about six
weeks this morning oklahoma hospitals
are at the brink every icu bed in the
state's capital city is full with dozens
of patients waiting for one to open i
try to
treat each patient like they're my
family
so
you know then it happened to my dad
and it's just it's different er nurse
nicole greene will spend 12 hours today
at a hospital slammed by covid as her 61
year old father brett battles for his
life at another he got sick last tuesday
was in the hospital on thursday on a
ventilator by friday but couldn't get an
icu bed until saturday night it's hard
you know
it's hard knowing and seeing what i've
seen and then
knowing that my there is a chance that
my dad could die
what would you tell dad right now
i would tell him to keep fighting
that we love him
and just keep fighting
it's a fight playing out hourly in icu's
and hospitals across the sooner state
prompting four of the largest hospital
groups to warn residents in an open
letter the oklahoma city health care
system is at a breaking point and
pleading with people to get vaccinated
and boosted statewide less than 55
percent are fully vaccinated right now
probably 80 percent of the people that
we actually have in the hospital are
unvaccinated saint anthony hospital
chief medical officer dr kirsty winfrey
was one of the letter's authors
how close are you to the worst case
scenario
i think that
on any given day you feel like you're in
it
at the present moment the next step the
hospitals are juggling too many patients
while dealing with staffing shortages
limited supplies of therapeutics and
even a shortage of oxygen containers
which forced 71 year old johnny carey
into a much sought after hospital bed
if i had oxygen i could have stayed home
never went
so a lot of the rooms that are full in
the hospital
is just because people can't get the
oxygen
now brett greene's family tells us
doctors are optimistic but it could be
several more days before they have a
clear prognosis and like so many people
we talked to here in oklahoma they did
not want to discuss vaccination status
it has become a polarizing issue that
hospitals say is so important if they're
going to get any kind of relief tony
chris van cleef from one of the new
epicenters of this search chris thank
you very much to